why are they taking the machines we got
busted it never even occurred to me that
the game was illegal but for over three
decades pinball was banned in New York
City most people have no idea that
pinball was illegal in New York from the
early 1940s until 1976 when a journalist
named Roger sharp finally won his
Crusade against the city to free the
flippers the story of that insane ban is
the subject of the new movie pinball the
man who saved the game which Richard
Brody of the New Yorker called better
than all 10 of the best picture nominees
the film was written and directed by
Austin Bragg and Meredith Bragg longtime
producers at reason best known for
collaborating with Remy on his massively
popular song parodies and for making
libertarian versions of Star Trek Star
Wars Game of Thrones and other pop
culture franchises
[Applause]
[Music]
who you're sending Holograms to is
information about you and your personal
life are you telling me the crown is
three million in death actually it's 20
trillion how could he let this happen
entitlement spending a bunch of wars
that bullet train to River Run didn't
help how did you hear about Roger sharp
in this story because it's I mean it's
it's just it's a great story that this
at first freelance journalist for GQ
ended up kind of changing a whole legal
regime I called email Roger um I got on
the phone with him and he told me about
all the other things meeting a single
mother and starting a relationship with
her his time at GQ his backstory that
made it more Universal it was a lot more
than just essentially a sports movie
about one person making a particular
shot in about three hours later I hung
up and I texted Austin and I said I
think this might be a feature this was
the first pinball machine I found in the
city it never even occurred to me that
the game was illegal I just knew I
needed to play
fiorella LaGuardia is kind of the
villain of the piece why did LaGuardia
ban pinball yeah LaGuardia came in
definitely on a crusade to stop
organized crime which I think was a
laudable goal but it was very hard to do
and it's very hard to to show people
that he was succeeding
in 1933 fiorella LaGuardia ran for mayor
promising to rid New York City of
corruption and organized crime pinball
he said was Campbell ruled by the mob a
racket to steal lunch money so he banned
it you know for the children and it
wasn't just a band it was a public
relations Crusade major raids throughout
the city squads of police swarming into
bowling alleys bars anywhere they could
find them let's talk about your body of
work at reason you're best known for
comedy videos you are principal
collaborators with Remy and doing the
song parodies do you have a favorite
Remy uh parody Or Remy video that you
guys have worked on I think that the one
that we did
um I think you edited it the black and
white with the oh well why we fought why
we fought and died I love that one if
you ask the dying Patriot he will tell
you that they fought four random
screenings at the airport with the TSA
all grabby while we play
parent plastic baggies and if you ask
them why they fought and die they'd give
you the same answer so you can get pics
taken of your junk while slowly getting
cancer I think you guys are are
particularly well known for the
libertarian takes on various things like
Star Wars Star Trek Game of Thrones and
then that vault is the Social Security
trust fund where all of the money goes
that will one day be paid out to
retirees
nothing yeah that's pretty much party
scheme
um what is the uh what's the secret
sauce There time
I mean truly it's about going through it
and looking for every opportunity to
take a Libertarian angle on something
[Music]
am I being detained I I'm filming you
I'm a
Republic Place
how did uh come to libertarianism we
grew up in a fairly conservative
household in a fairly liberal area so I
think it was pretty natural that we
ended up somewhere between the two I
remember in an early interview Nick with
Penn Gillette and he said I don't
believe that I or anyone else has the
right answers for other people about how
to live their life and that that
resonates pretty strongly with me and I
don't think there's anything you can do
more insulting than acting like you know
what's best for someone else
that I think instilled in me this idea
that um we should allow again I'm going
to steal another phrase of experiments
in living and allowing people to
flourish you know to pursue their own
happiness as long as they're not a
detriment to someone else doing that
he's not he's not hurting anyone by
playing pinball
much